wer sind eigentlich deutschlands
berühmteste werbestars ist einfach finde
ich an 1 klementine von ariel dann
natürlich tilly von palmolive und
neuerdings julia von nestlé ja unsere
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
hat den nächsten schritt zum an der
backe für ein absurdes twitter video mit
dem chef von nestlé deutschland
nestlé ist inbegriff oder ja dieser
sympathische konzern der zum beispiel
weltweit wasserrechte kauft und den
menschen dann ihr eigenes grundwasser in
flaschen zurück fertigt unter anderem
auch im süden von afrika und in
äthiopien
kurz gesagt mit solchen leuten will man
eigentlich nicht gesehen werden aber die
julia ist sich halt von nichts essen und
trinken ist wichtig aber die frage ist
ist es mit unserer umwelt gut vereinbar
und ist es vor allen dingen gut für
unsere gesundheit
diese fragen können wir im zusammenhang
mit messi fertigfutter alle klar mit
nein beantworten
julia klöckner persönlich verhindert
weiter eine einfache lebensmittelampel
wie den nutrias chor in frankreich der
dem verbraucher auf einen blick sagen
würde
lasst die scheiße im regal bufett sauna
entschuldigung dann kann ich mich doch
nicht gleichzeitig mit dem nestlé chef
zum pr termin treffen ist jetzt
offiziell lobbyisten oder was also ich
kann selber denken uns die unterstellung
dass man irgendwie lobbyist von anderen
sei das ist natürlich sehr sportlich was
sie da gerade tun
auch danke sportlich
das höre ich oft so wir schalten live
erscheint mal live nach berlin zum
bundesministerium für ernährung und
landwirtschaft dort leitet albrecht
humboldt die neue abteilung für gesunde
ernährung und dicke kinder
warum wollt was sollte denn bitten
dieser auftritt mit dem nest lehmann
also jetzt ist aber auch langsam mal gut
herweck ernährungstipps von dem
moderator für den das 16 9-format quasi
erfunden wurde
was war denn bitte an dem auftritt
werbung das war einfach ein nettes
gespräch hat viel neues erfahren und
freue mich dass wir unterstützung haben
für unsere innovations- und reduktion
strategie weniger zucker weniger salz
weniger fett in den produkten die die
bürger gerne melden liegt am meer oder
hat sie gerade gesagt die bürger mögen
gerne nestlé produkt ja gut da ist ihr
tatsächlich ein lapsus passiert
produkte die die bürger gerne mögen das
ist natürlich viel zu allgemein die
hatten eigentlich mit ihr besprochen
dass sie an der stelle ein paar konkrete
marken erwähnt ich hole das mal kurz
nach marken wie sie nehmen dies der
ideale start in den tag für unsere
kleinen diabetiker von morgen denn
zucker schmeckt nur mit ganz ganz viel
sind oder die fünf minuten terrine denn
manchmal ist glutamat teuer
und zum nachtisch ein schönes glas
nesquik aha flüssige carius die auch
noch lecker schmeckt nesquik danke laura
nesquik nesquik ist ein super beispiel
100 gramm nesquik enthalten gerade mal
76 gramm zucker
so und jetzt will der nestlé konzern
freiwillig diesen zuckergehalt um
weitere fünf prozent reduzieren dann
sind das nur noch 72 gramm sowas denn
nur noch wenn sie noch mehr zucker da
rausnehmen schmeckt die chöre salzig
hast in über 70 ländern gibt es steuer
auf ungesunde lebensmittel werbeverbote
oder deutliche warnhinweise auf der
packung warum nicht bei uns weil das
hier immer noch ein freies land ist in
dem jeder deutsche selber entscheidet
wie sehr die hose kneift oder wann die
leber platzt weder rationieren wir was
noch geben wir ein budget vor noch
verbieten wir das eine oder andere
getränk
unterdessen zeigt die neue britische
steuer wirkung die meisten getränke
hersteller auch coca cola haben ihren
zuckeranteil kurz vor dem start der
abgabe deutlich gesenkt ja england das
kann man nicht vergleichen
da haben die meisten ja eh keine zähne
mehr
der deutschen setzen weiter auf
freiwilligkeit
warum sollte die industrie freiwillig
auf billige geschmacks geber wie zucker
und fett verzichten in deutschland haben
wir nicht mal klare gesetzliche regeln
für werbung die sich an kinder richtet
ach ja meinen sie etwa die kinder die
für ihr leben gern - eis essen am nokia
eis das lustige waffeleis vergnügen
enthält teilweise echte nüssel
ein weiteres premium produkt aus dem
hause nestlé
albrecht meine damen und herren
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's hier raus
scheiße